initialized itself so i'm just going to
talk
over this i might as well say we're at
30
so once you can hear us just just start
telling us
60 is a good sign just stop to stop
start
saying when you can hear us
i think me thinks i think we're live me
thinks
we are live if we are live
say it say it hey kitty cat don't spray
it
hey kitty cat we live we live kitty cat
talking that jive kitty cat
i'm on the part of agents of [ __ ] you're
dealing with live
kitty cat hi okay so you guys can hear
us we're good
yes we always have trouble going live we
do
but today was pretty smooth actually we
haven't done a live stream
in many weeks we were doing it weekly
for such a long time
yeah up until now we're finally live
again oh hi thank you lana i just saw
that and oh and he says thank you
wow there's so many people here thank
you so much i appreciate it guys
so many happy birthdays i normally like
to shout out everyone's name at the top
oh my god and you were sitting here
no one's going to show up hey mimi hey
you know yeah i was literally like what
are people
nobody cares there's not a specific
topic oh man
ah koala guy no audio are you lying
and david9
daniel king age of the witch thank you
guys so much king jason 20. i saw a jive
turkey
oh so sweet so oh melanie
this is this is going to be the stream
i'm just going to be looking at everyone
saying happy birthday to me
whoa thank you that's bad thank you so
much yeah
mr bond oh you must be having a good day
mr bond
here's what i asked for my birthday hit
that [ __ ] like button
hit that like button turn on
notifications this is gonna be a fun one
can't really go out because of cobin so
i figured might as well go live today
get crunk in the office thank you so
much to everyone saying that
everyone's so sweet thank you guys oh my
goodness
but yeah i just thought today and happy
birthday to your aunt there gotcha
stitches
um john strega lopez studios your camera
is green
yeah it's a little blue right now it's
still blue today
we can change it give give them a little
behind the scenes here behind the
curtain give them a little behind the
scenes
this is typically yeah saved for like
patreon but here
oh oh that's normally what it's like
it's yellow look at that it's yeah it's
more time did you prefer it before or
after are you a tungsten or are you a
daylight
how many kelvins do you want um so yeah
i thought
okay i'm so overwhelmed i just watched
this video that we're gonna put up later
on patreon
um a bunch of people from discord um and
our patreon put
anissa shepard at it yeah i made this
compilation of little lovely people
saying something very lovely thanks to
me it [ __ ] blew my mind
i was crying um why is our camera jacked
up
i don't know man it's the card reader
something's wrong with our card reader
that's why
uh well and you know when in these days
with kids going back to school and stuff
like internet being taxed and doing like
hd
interlacing live it's a lot i i really
think
it's a lot of process i really think um
we should go to the blue again give them
the blue give them the blue
behind the scenes go back to the blue
give them the blue you know
why because bradley keeps saying snyder
cut
why don't you try white fluorescence
let's try white fluorescence yeah yeah
you might want to hit that button again
john
yeah look at that oh it's some behind
the scenes for you behind
the scenes see yeah some people are just
talking about the twilight filter you
know i'm wondering maybe we should just
do the twilight filter dude let's go
back to the blue
johnny bring it back to the blue your
favorite filter go back to the blue
super chat for your favorite white
balance
boom that's the filter right now that's
the color we're going to use
there's a snyder cut blue color to this
one yeah this is the david's
so sure if anyone asks why the color
camera looks like this because if we're
going for the snyder cup blue look right
here yeah it's all about the snare cut
here is this channel
um all right so let's look at the chat
right now let's see what you guys are
all
saying all right we will definitely play
madden 21 that's all we're gonna do
uh reactions for in the next year it's
my birthday today
it's my birthday today um didn't do it
for john's i said [ __ ] you john no wait
we were doing showdown and we were
behind on patreon videos yeah
then we met up and we shot supernatural
right yeah that's what we did
and then i took you to get burger king
yes the titans color filter see this is
like a dc
look in honor of dc's greatness
thank you kj i really appreciate it
right now anissa almost had coven 19 she
beat it
she killed it and if anyone says happy
[ __ ] birthday
their comment gets hidden for some
reason oh because you're tuning it right
there
youtube doesn't want you to swear
because it's bad for your teeth
thank you so much your face might get
stuck that way happy 14th birthday
you look 14 today you're the the
beardiest 14 year old
all right um okay so yeah i'm 30 today
the camera's showing lag on the frames
it'll pick up eventually it's just the
area where i have
the uh you know it's the area where i
have uh where we have our internet set
up it's a bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ] time warner spectrum
it's fine i'm like no it's not guys
could stop telling me my internet's fine
yeah it works but it's not
fine it's not what you promised me and
yeah i did hear about robert pattinson
testing positive that sucks
i know him and dwayne johnson's family
it's weird you know i feel like they're
going to be fine
when celebrities first started getting
it when tom hanks got it
when andrew selva and tom hanks how were
like whoa [ __ ] no [ __ ] no
no no this can't be happening right
don't take our hanks but we've seen a
lot of celebrities who were kind of
actually flying under the radar who had
it
and some people who kept it really quiet
they didn't tell anyone in the pa i
think kevin hart had it at one point
and he just kept that really silent um
i feel like they'll be fine you know
it's always worrisome
it's like the rock especially with his
kind of immune system it's got to have a
crazy immune system
what's funny is when i first heard about
robert pattinson getting it
i didn't hear that many people concerned
if he'd overcome it
what i mainly heard was oh [ __ ] the
batman's game delayed
we should slow this down it's not let's
talk a little bit
first about how we should be a concern
if someone gets
diagnosed with this i hope our paths is
okay
yeah i hope he's okay
uh why do i look like a street snack i
don't know i don't know
all right oh we got some fans from india
here thank you so much
jaby kawaii must have said something so
i see some of you guys have sent some
super chats so i do want to take a look
at them before we lag too long
did not see any of those mario
announcements
no there's going to be a new mario if
there's always a new mario
always as long as there's nintendo
what'd you guys think of that bond
trailer by the way
do you think you should team up with
mario yeah yeah
that would be great that's the smash
brothers character we need
all right happy birthday to you too
ashley happy b
day it's also charlie sheen's birthday
shouts out to charlie
sheen charlie sheen all right oh damn
things have things have switched around
oh
on our end yes okay okay it's okay
though let's blow this up a little bit
and let's see
who we can thank you to everyone here
contributing to these super chats right
here you so very much yeah
hi to colorado everyone from new york
thank you to everyone here has been
wishing a happy birthday
just hit that like button that's all i
ask that's all i asked for
so numero uno we got a nice
she said to us she said happy birthday
what's your favorite b
day memory oh my favorite b
day memory yeah god john um
you know i don't i i definitely had a
great memory today
like the a lot of the patronage made as
several of them put like work together
to and anissa edited it
of giving me some very sincere happy
birthday wishes and i've never been so
touched by personal video messages
before
brought me to tears yeah that was very
good um that was really um that was very
touching i would say that's definitely
made the list
of favorite birthday memories i really
do i really do love that one
and uh we did hit a million uh views on
the batman trailer
so that was last week yeah so it was an
early day
it was an early birthday present yeah
birthday present from the dc fandom that
had to be that had to be one of them
um i'm not i don't want to get too
specific to get my girlfriend in trouble
but there was one birthday party i had
where she was a little drunk and
started saying something she was gonna
give me
we were like okay and it was a great
birthday present
gotta be a little discreet about that
but it was a good one
thank you to everyone who's been saying
um happy birthday to me right now oh
hell yeah
and then one time um i went to chuck e
cheese that was great
erica tuesday in the chat thank you so
much thank you to everyone who's here
right now
oh i hope you're watching from the hot
tub lana pico
hey lana lana is real on my way
but wanted to make sure to stop and wish
you a happy birthday greg thank you for
being one half of my favorite youtube
duo enjoy thirty
she means me and akkason and and
yeah don't those collabs
no when you guys get together the real
magic happens that [ __ ] akkason
is the [ __ ] it is why doesn't he come on
more
yeah man no thank you lana that's really
sweet you're constantly on our live
streams that means a hell of a lot to me
um no i haven't seen the new nintendo
direct by the way a lot of people in the
chat have been asking about that
and thank you saya for the nice words
erica tuesday erica
michael b michael b
ever since i watched rick and morty i
have a habit of shouting [ __ ] like him
and that tonality
michael b michael b rick pickle rick
oh might as well hey john got me this
pickle rick funko pop
yeah there there are many there are a
few varieties but i thought the the big
laser gun in the battery was pretty cool
and one of my sh
one of my presents from olivia is his
friend shirt too i was about to ask it's
a great [ __ ] shirt
best show in the world i love it 30
today i'm 30 today
you're also 30 today ashley that's great
oh damn hey
don't worry we're looking at the chat
the whole the whole time erica thank you
for being here
for as long as you can um but michael b
follow this [ __ ] on youtube he's
so great at what he does
he is he is amazing he's sincerely mean
it he's a great youtuber if you like
this
channel you'll kind of like his
so go there today go there today and
then you feel lukewarm for yourself
seriously seriously go check him out i
want to collab with him in person one of
these days
that would be rad ooh oh varun i'm
seeing your super chat a little bit
early and i gotta tell you uh yeah
that's in the works
sia di diakite saya
diakite um birthday gift happy 30th
birthday
thank you sia super sweet of you thank
you thank you so much
on behalf of greg what does c i mean i
don't know let's let's find
out let's go to the googs no no no john
there's always a more entertaining way
of doing it yes
get on your phone yeah get on your phone
during the live
stream and let me give you crap about it
for once no
olivia and i are a-okay we work things
out
i let her sleep with another guy
everything's fine oh good
yeah finally that's well it's usually
what olivia does
to to make sure we stay together
i can't be happy unless i sleep with
another guy and i go
all right whatever makes you happy and
then i
watch bringing back ryan rat today
i once saw a t-shirt that i or no it was
like a button down that i really kind of
wanted to get and just
across the shoulders it just said cuck
like
i was like yeah well thank you sia
um jean jeter tv he says happy
happy birthday mother shut your mouth
greg
lol just kidding have a great day and
weekend dude dude
jean jeter you have been such a long
time follower of us
and you are such a creative dude and
whenever i get to hear your voice which
is rare i'm always grateful to hear you
got a very nice voice gene
there was a hot second there where you
were sending me little voice messages on
instagram and yeah i felt special
yeah i felt special about it amber thank
you for celebrating at the pub by the
way that means a hell of a lot
thank you which pub let us know kenoi
it's your birthday today too
hey it's always [ __ ] weird when you
have the same birthday as somebody else
this day is becoming less special yeah
what the [ __ ] it's like when you see
someone who wears the same shirt as you
yeah like you [ __ ] [ __ ] uh they
did print thousands of those
didn't they sometimes i see someone
wearing the same shirt
as me and i i never know whether or not
i should
say something to you yeah like what the
[ __ ] or just go the other way and not
get into this conversation
now do you ever to go one step further
do you ever have it where you see
somebody else wearing a shirt that you
own
you're not wearing right now but just
that you own and that you like
and so for a hot segue you're like that
shirt's a good shirt
yeah yeah i have that shirt too because
then
are they gonna be upset that they're not
unique because they know you have it
there's a louis ck bid based on this oh
and he's back
i'm glad john you're quoting louis ck on
this stream today hey
now we know how easy it was for dane
cook to do the same and now i totally
believe him
he didn't steal his jokes back in the
day that's my defense
oh man phoenix phoenix 49
5. 49.5 q a
hmm how old i'll be 25 well happy early
birthday to your
day i turned 30 today and
um i already feel like i need a prostate
exam
that's what's happening today get a
prostate examination
worried i might enjoy it a little too
much hey yeah have you seen american pie
i might need to rub one out before i
go into that prostate exam that's a
sketch waiting to happen like a dude
who's going to a prostate exam but he's
jerking off first because he doesn't
want to finish too fast during the exam
yeah oh goodness gracious
oh john is not camping i get cancelled
every one of these live streams
if john is to ever be cancelled it's
gonna be by me yeah
no one else no i can yeah and i would i
wouldn't want to be
canceled by anybody else all right
there's and trust me there's been plenty
of evidence
to go up against john yeah plenty of
evidence and
i'm telling you guys i'll be able to
cancel the guy
one of your cats want to come in here oh
come on but come on cat there's room
enough for the two of you
there's enough room for them for both of
you to come in here terrorism lifestyle
okay okay we got two cats who are
staring each other down right now
watson come here all right i'm taught in
two
niraj krishnan thank you dude
thank you buddy niraj sent me over a
list of vegan indian options because i'm
pescatarian
and olivia's vegetarian so gonna be
getting some indian food at some point
in the
very near future that is a good cause
thank you narage means a hell of a lot
call indian food is delicious anissa if
you were to cry if jon ever got
cancelled you better prepare those tears
they're on the way
this is just a great day for me i use my
birthday as an opportunity to warn you
guys
john's on his way to getting cancer
there's so much you don't know
my birthday is a chance to make you feel
as uncomfortable
as possible that's the plan man fear for
your
livelihood mr bond
the name's james bond
james bond i'll have a margarita i'll
have a margarita that's i love you man
best movie
he says hashtag release the alba cut do
it
dude what albaco what are you talking
about
which thing have you been like you know
petitioning or ranting if you're talking
about my documentary expose to cancel
john don't worry that cut is on its way
oh any cut of that is the albuquerque
i'm happy
i'm having john edited himself
and i'm making sure he's fact-checking
he's coming don't worry it's coming it's
on the way guys
and then mads is uh he sent a sticker
here
you are amazing you are amazing thank
you so much dude
he sent me 219 knock which in
um that country yes that equates to 3
000
over too much holy [ __ ] dude send over
another 250 knock and i can ship the
heroine to your house as soon as
possible dude
along with a copy of john kennedy
i love don't you love exchange rates oh
thank you guys thank you so much
james pond james font all right so uh
let's go back to thank you guys so i
know we got some more but i want to see
what's going on in the chat right now i
want to give i want to give my full
attention to there heck yeah
hoopla um all right so let's see thank
you guys for so much for everyone who's
been hopping in here and saying happy
birthday
heck yeah oh yeah that's what you mean
because i need the oh the movie couples
in the stream hey wendy hey dusty
oh how's it called dusty ash fan that's
so sweet
thank you this is great you open up the
door for a q a
and what you get is a lot of people
sweet people saying happy birthday and a
lot of people just showing love and
complimenting
my friends it's a little harder to
riffle just a compliment
that's me deflecting because i'm so
touched so thank you here we go i got a
question from chase in here
um craig you have to choose between
being an avenger or meet some
somewhere avenger on your birthday who
will it be happy birthday
i guess what he's saying is who like
which if if who would you mean on your
birthday
yeah yeah which avenger would you want
to meet on your birthday which avenger
would i want to meet on my birthday
i would definitely out of all the
avengers i feel like um
i mean just for the sake of memory as
right now it would be black panther yeah
i would say right now be black panther i
would be most inspired
that yeah you know if i was you to get
some wakandan technology
condian technology yeah yeah because
they have the best tech on earth
yeah um yeah that would be pretty
amazing um
and then and then i would want to meet
i'd want to meet
thor when he was in thor the dark world
phase
where he's not funny where he's really
what kind of gentleman he is yeah i that
that'll get a revival at some point when
thor gets too silly and people get tired
of that we'll just take it right back to
brooding shakespearean
epic guys look if you're defending john
right now in this stream
i just want you to know that you're
going to really want to take those words
back
yeah the way how a lot of people have
felt with defending amber hurt and being
like oh [ __ ] what have i done
goddamn that i pooped it's how you're
going to feel he [ __ ] in my bag
twice all right
let that sink in for y'all hashtag
john's standing your ground
he has no ground to stand i don't have a
ground understand john is getting cancer
right here i'm making it happen i'm
making sure
embarrassing yourself with these
defenses guys
um shin 58 any games you guys have been
playing recently
i've been playing batman arkham city i
want to get through i want to beat the
batman franchise right now
and i've really been enjoying that jon
have you i've been playing pocket mortys
i have been playing pokemon go
and i've been playing um uh
you played any consoles jon um
no not in a minute damn it console game
but
uh i finally found my stash of all the
consoles
and uh i'm going to hook up the ps3 how
did you lose your stash of cards how do
you lose a stash i didn't want to i
didn't lose it what do you mean i
found my stash of consoles like what
what the [ __ ] are you doing
what the hell is going on here how do
you not have like imagine
where are you reimagined but doc
brown is just an intense gamer that
[ __ ] said no no no no no no uh i i
had a box
of them and i had them all organized
away because there wasn't any like
yeah i hadn't lost them i just hadn't
thought about the box and then i was
moving some stuff around and and making
some space for some things i was getting
rid of and then i
uh i found a place where it might be
convenient to set them up is what i'm
trying to get at so
finally i can put them because you know
like
yeah the way my space is designed i i
had to get creative
so very cool very cool this was very
cool yeah uh yeah it's been a minute
since i played console game the last
time i played a console game was
was like the last time we all like did
verses in mortal kombat or something
i have played the spider-man ps4 game
love the [ __ ] out of that
game that's a great one i did talk about
the with the patterson getting covered
my main concern is patents and healing
right now yeah all right get better
like as much of a bummer it would be for
like for batman getting delayed
it's very important first and foremost
that he's healthy
and that the rest of the cast and crew
are also
going to be healthy moving forward that
is priority number one
i love i i have 100 faith he's going to
get better
and all i really care about is that and
um if batman gets delayed because of it
fine
i'm okay with the delay all right if the
fact that they have a [ __ ] trailer
that's only
25 to 30 percent of footage and it looks
that
amazing yeah off of 70
of the movie not being shot i'm okay
with it being a little delayed guys
yeah and also i mean just because that
look at it was so gripping and so good
i feel like that'll also just build the
anticipation yes
and anticipation is is you got to meet
it but it's also one of the most fun
parts of being a fan
so we got some more super chats thank
you guys to everyone's contributing to
super chaps uh
super chat super chaps super chaps the
greatest ass in the world
this list super chat shop i love it i
love it
um uh but we also uh we also have some
might be someone in stream labs right
now but either way get us caught up onto
the super chats okay here we are and uh
and yeah
if uh it was over here john it will be
it'll move back uh and yeah we also have
our stream labs link open if you don't
want
youtube to take 40 percent uh
or whatever that is uh yeah we're also
open over on stream labs no pressure but
just you know
it's not a big deal all i care about is
that if you're here you hit the like
button
that's my main concern hit the like
button that's that's it but yeah
if you want to go more direct we also
have stream labs and it's up to you
it's up to you um anissa's back sorry
john
i didn't do the video for your birthday
next year
you're lucky i'm having a birthday next
year so you're gonna read the super
chats
on
amber heard amber jones i think or no
ashley it was an ashley girl yeah i've
had a couple people sharing there's a
couple people here
who have the same birthday as me today
um
but yeah she didn't make you one i guess
you don't matter as much
you know it makes sense if anybody's
gonna if there's only gonna be one video
it should be free
yeah um bradley bledsoe
who is a crazy editor crazy
gray bananas um happy birthday greg
here's a question
here's a fun question if you guys can
meet i'm glad we're doing the live
stream today because john campia isn't
doing a live stream today
so we can so we are supplementing for
champions right here he didn't have
anything good to talk about what we do
i was like campya it's my birthday watch
talk about that
stuff for three hours why didn't you do
a three-hour livestream with robert
meyer burnett
talking about correct today i think it's
great that craig's having a what
what's the [ __ ] what's the problem man
just do it
and our first topic today our first
topic today
comes from user bradley bledsoe
um happy birthday craig here's a
question
if you guys can meet any historical
musical figure
who would it be and why have a good one
guys
okay so i'm assuming this is inspired by
bill and ted so if we're talking like
historical figure it's got to be someone
who has probably passed on right yeah
okay i would want to meet i don't know
if this qualifies in this category the
man
i would want to meet who's probably been
the most
moving in my life and as a musician who
i followed who has passed on
would have to be johnny cash johnny cash
would be the main guy i'd want to meet
like his
it's weird how he played like the same
five chords for three thousand songs
and yeah his music was so influential
yeah
it's like the same chords all the time
if you ever want to learn guitar
and you want to learn johnny cash songs
you're like wow it's
it's the same five to seven chords every
time
but yeah i would say um i would say
johnny cash would be the main historical
musician i want to meet one living today
would undoubtedly be anthony [ __ ]
kids from the red hot chili peppers that
would be the one today i would want to
meet and thank you for your super chat
bradley thank you to everyone else who
contributed to the super chats today
okay i think and yeah freddie mercury
why the [ __ ] not everything that's
pretty cool uh i would want
i mean to honor my young inner child
what am i trying to say to honor like
what helped me fall in love with guitar
in the first place and music in the
first place like jimi hendrix's red
house rendition was just like such a
huge moment in my
young life that yeah like i grew up just
like yeah idolizing just his work on the
guitar and so if i was talking about
like historical musical figure
part of me wants to have like a more
deep cut answer but i feel like yeah
jimmy would be one or chester bennington
to go more recently like i wish i could
have met
like met him for real because uh lincoln
park and especially chester was just
like such a huge part of again like my
my young life and they like they're not
necessarily the band i listen to
the way you listen to your favorite band
anymore but they are like they always
hold the spot in my heart as one of my
favorites and stuff
and uh yeah that's great john thanks
greg thanks
i'm gonna put you on a timer when you're
talking on my birthday on your own
all right john's getting canceled today
i want to meet greg
i'm going to meet greg in the future
once this video's done once this stream
is done i am uploading a video
that'll prove johnny get cancelled this
will start this will break the damn of
people getting canceled for stuff that's
just annoying i'm going to start making
people getting canceled an event
a celebration count down to cancel down
to cancellation
hit premiering this youtube video cancel
count
dude that's perfect you could be the
culture john's my first victim
today that only makes sense yeah they
didn't get andrew gordon then
get all of our collaborators here's why
there's been a lack of gas let's not do
the covid
it's because they're all getting
cancelled i knew nothing but bad
[ __ ]
nfx visuals uh nfx visuals thank you
happy birthday thank you so much you
must have a great visual channel dude
all right john i have a birthday present
to ask you what
from big mo logan thank you by the way
for contributing
can you read big mo logan's um
super chat in your uh nicholas cage
voice
happy birthday happy 30th birthday twin
i turned 25 today so i'm gonna look back
at your 2015 videos
and compare your life progress by 25 to
mine
and then i'm going to take your face
thank you john you're welcome and thank
you big mo logan you don't want to
compare man
everyone is on a different timeline
everyone's on a different track a
different path some people hit
like sam jackson didn't hit success till
like his 40s
yeah you know and um like
if i were to compare to myself to like
tyrone magnus which you should which i
should all right so if he's at a million
point eight 1.8 million followers right
now
and he's like 43 if i'm at 1.8 million
followers by the time
i'm 43 i'm on the right track
the gauge but no i've i actually
not a lot of people like this guy and i
go back and forth on some things he says
but jordan peterson did say something
that i thought was very fascinating
and uh i have applied it as a rule of
thumb he said
that you don't want to compare yourself
to others you want to compare yourself
to who you were yesterday
and a lot of times especially in this
youtube game i think a lot of people can
ease
like every youtuber i know most of them
and i won't say everyone but
majority of them have it's so
easy to compare yourself to other
youtubers
if they're at all in the same category
whatsoever
and looking at their their views versus
their subscribers it's a very easy thing
for people to fall under
and uh i think it's because it's just
one click away from finding out your
comparison you know what i mean
it's it's so easy to compare because
it's all the information's just
right there oh and you can tip your
fingers to compare yourself you know and
you can keep going
yeah keep comparing and one of my
favorite songs is the
baslerman sunscreen song and he said
there's a line in that speech of
sometimes you're ahead sometimes you're
behind but
at the end of the day the race is long
and at the end and at the end of the day
it's only with yourself is what he says
and so yeah i mean i i have a habit of
like i can get into my
phases where i'm comparing myself um but
the best thing to do is to only compare
yourself to yourself
so yeah oh yeah and happy birthday
big big mo logan yeah yeah and uh happy
belated birthday to gustavo i saw in the
chat
uh tariq allen thank you and yes happy
birthday to that other
gentleman who the name you said uh tariq
allen happy birthday greg i hope i was
at your channel
you don't want to be here nope no no
it's a nightmare behind the scenes it's
really aggressive there's a reason john
is getting canceled today that's that's
i haven't done anything to get canceled
that's how bad things are
that's how grim this is welcome to the
real world john
varun kumar um happy birth thank you
verone for contributing
happy birthday greg bring back cat
alvarado please
i'm going to take a photo of this and
i'm going to send it
to cat alvarado oh she's gonna feel
so she has we've been talking uh she
wants me to go back on her podcast
and i want to bring her back on too and
she's been pretty healthy so far
so yeah so far so far in the apocalypse
um but thank you i'll let her know we
love you too stephen baker
and uh saya diakite says
thank you for existing my friend oh i'm
happy to exist
it's good that you exist i know and it's
good that you acknowledge you exist
because if you didn't you might not
exist hmm
i think therefore i was great comedy
guys
yeah man theoretical economy about
science and existentialism is great all
right let's read one more then i want to
go back to the chat and see what
crazy things you guys are talking about
in there percy tremblet that's a good
name what a great name percy tremblet
that sounds like a legendary name and
then that that strikes
fear into the names of villains percy
they tremble at the name of percy
trembling
happy birthday brah welcome to the 30s
club
dude so excited to be here i hear life
is smooth sailing
here on out man everybody's instagram
they're all out like yeah 30 that's when
i've released
30 is the new 20 because it's the new
age decade that everybody sells you as
being like
great and carefree and tariq allen
is saying i wish i can come to your
channel soon we'll we'll have to talk it
out tariq
dude we'll have to talk it out i once
had a guy out here named tariq i haven't
talked to him in a long time but he was
a really funny guy
where is he find him not sure all right
guys thank you we're going to go back to
the chats and all that in a second but i
want to see what's going on
in the in the stream itself right now
what crazy things are you guys talking
about what's going on in the stream
all right favorite birthday meal all
right got it i got it
john i want to hear yours too okay but
keep it keep it short
this isn't john's day this is john's
cancels day correct
birthday yeah john's cancelled today
no one forget that yes cancelled
cancellation you don't even know why
it's set in stone i am canceled
that would be the greatest birthday
present if i could just get that
trending
cancel john is cancelled and no one
knows
everyone's just like i'm looking for
information i can't put anything on
trump why he's cancelled
john is cancelled birthday party that
would be my first that would be my
favorite thing in the world
has canceled birthday party should we
make the camera brighter all right
so just every 10 minutes change the
camera settings
all right so um favorite dave again you
sent me something on twitter i gotta
check that
um favorite birthday food i love a damn
good
cheese pizza it's a classic cheese pizza
pizza party
with pineapple and extra cheese on it
and
a side of mozzarella sticks and some
garlic cheese bread
the goal is here's how i eat on my
birthday this is why it's gonna be so
hard to film again tomorrow
where i might be really tired if we put
up a new youtube video tomorrow all
right
because on my birthday here's how i eat
i
eat i eat till i just want to die
and then i lay down and then once i got
a little more room left in my stomach
i just keep on going and it's just a
constant cycle
until i wake up the next day going i
should never do that again
and then i do it again next weekend
so that's my six cycles john what's your
favorite birthday food
sushi moving on okay why don't you like
make keep it short but make it a little
engaging all right geez i don't i mean i
just i love sushi and it's one of those
foods that's like
specific and pricey enough that it's you
know kind of like a special occasion
food in my mind and yeah you could just
eat it all
the they'll live long day perfect you
did a job
i'd do my best uh one day we'll come to
england mark leech
oh and a good likes coffee stout or
something yeah
hi hi maria hammond hi maria nice to see
you in the chat
yo yo nah man i would never want to
verse tyrone he's a
tyron's a great guy tyron's a great guy
he is
he is uh what happened to the scary
video reactions we should probably
continue those
dude i appreciate that yeah let's do it
i mean i i always love a scary video
plus we did those loot frights
favorite sushi what's your favorite
sushi john oh
man that's a tough one anything i i like
things
we have this 3d effect going don't we
yeah we do
look at that what is up with this card
reader it has been faulty for we got the
same one recommended to us
by a pretty popular live streamer and it
has had this
not the same quality effect at all you
know what we need to do is we need to
run
a a test and see if we're just [ __ ]
moving tron in here well yeah because
the
it's trying to lace all the colors
together live and i
i wonder if it would be the same
look if uh uh we were just recording
straight into like a quicktime file or
something
you know yeah all right fair enough
although
i mean you know we can always try a
different capture card
all right so let's see yeah it does look
have like this 3d effect
yeah i like rolls i like sushi that has
like a spicer kick
i know right so kevin kersten i feel
like i'm on dmt
watching this video doesn't it look like
it
yeah this looks like a [ __ ] trippy
experience i
i honestly don't i mean it's feeding out
of an hdmi through a capture card into a
usb into
just into stream labs that streamer did
sabotage us tm
yeah man i think he's a [ __ ] liar
yeah we gotta get an elgato that's the
only solution he's the next one to get
cancelled
yes all right
so aren't they better this way though
aren't they more
fun this way i like things that have
spicy tuna and general spice in general
but rainbow roll is kind of like my just
like if i gotta go with one thing and
peace out and make it easy that's what i
go with
yeah fair enough you know i like variety
uh bradley bradley do you have edibles
my friend
be careful man oh dude hang on to your
hat
um okay but i wanted to
whoa hold on a sec hey is anyone
watching mulan today
is anyone watching that anybody i've
heard it's perfectly
okay hey i mean rosa said it was one of
her favorite live-action disney movies
this year disney uh remakes so i'm that
gave me some hope in it kevin shepard if
you want to audition replace
john absolutely yeah i'm i've been
holding auditions here's
here's since the me too movement here's
how you do it
you just come in here and you fix the
lacing on this image and then you can
have my spot
if you can fix this 3d effect
then i'll write that maybe you should
watch the stream with red and blue
glasses
maybe if we just stay still what do you
think it is
i honestly think that it's just because
we're streaming 1080p live
into a capture card it's just working so
hard to
do why are we doing 1080p then
um i don't know if we can most people
watching on their phones
well if you want to go to 640 and have
like a a square frame
yeah that'd be great let's just make
this let's go off-road all right guys
this is an off-road stream let's
let me let me see if i can remember how
to get there you got this john
all right i don't know if he's going to
destroy everything
there you go there you go now we're
oh look we're not now we're low quality
well now we're low quality and look at
the weird framing we have here
yeah now yeah oh my god are we crystal
clear
this has been the first time oh no
there's some there's some oh no bring it
back john bring it back damn it
bring it back john i don't know i mean i
mean maybe the streamer who gave us that
piece of advice maybe they
have one that cause i'm gonna be having
a talk with him maybe they have one that
cost like five hundred dollars john it's
craig's birthday fix the camera
guys you know what well now it looks
super
dark doesn't it well yeah we should we
should we should stop there we go now
we're super bright now we're too bright
look at john it looks like it looks like
the character from prometheus
yeah i'm the engineer the founder of the
engineers
i'm gonna because we have this like
weird blue lighting and you're super
pale
this is great i'm gonna google this i'm
gonna google solutions to this
no i didn't worry about it man yeah
exactly snyder cup
filter um what superpower would i want
the superpower
i would really want is gonna sound like
a [ __ ] up thing but if i'm being
honest
i want specifically not to do what
killgrave did
but i want to kill graves powers because
i don't really want to read
people's minds because i feel like
that'd be a [ __ ]
one thing that i feel like what i've
always wanted to see with reading
people's minds
when like professor xavier first learns
he's able to read people's minds
he uh he'll hear chaos everywhere right
that's usually what happens with mind
readers like oh i hear everyone's
thoughts
but if but isn't it like if if someone
with someone's brain wave patterns
they're having like a gazillion thoughts
firing at once right yeah it's like a
whole bunch of thoughts so
if you were to hone in on one person's
brain to read their mind
it would be like thumbing through like
encyclopedias should be like
chaos yeah so no i don't want it
but i would like kilgrave's power so i
could be like
hey give me
your sandwich something you know
and they just do it i definitely steal
people's food you want the power to
compel people
yeah yeah but i want to take advantage
of people in like a creepy way yeah
but you know if like you didn't want to
give me an extra fry i'd be like
give me your fry and your barbecue sauce
and your wallet and your shirt and your
wife
um i'm not bullying john you're gonna
find out in that documentary today this
is awesome well yeah i had this coming a
long time
um all right john so we got some super
chat sketches we should we should hit up
uh the stream labs
we got a couple streams we got a couple
stream labs john pull it up
do the thing you do john that thing you
do do the thing you do johnny i don't
think that's actually the melody but you
know i'm doing my best
all right look at that we're loading up
oh my goodness
we got three three individuals here all
right so
mr eric horseman i put
some of this on instagram the full thing
is going up on patreon later
he got um steven spielberg
richard spacey richard spate jr who
plays trickster slash loki on
supernatural
did it got a cameo video yeah sent it to
me
i was so surprised that was legit cool
the video's going up a little bit later
thank you eric horseman that's really
sweet
uh he says ah sorry i'm late happy
birthday well
thank you dude dude you don't need to
contribute anymore i appreciate it
though buddy thank you
you're good and erica tuesday erica
tuesday
yeah pickle rick says happy happy
birthday greg babe
imagine that this is a corny birthday
card because i'm giving this gift
grandma style
one dollar for each year and i was about
to say i'm not 31 what the [ __ ] and one
more for good luck
glad you were born have a good one o s
frog what does os frog mean
um john you know erica better than i do
i'm not sure what os
frog is well araco s frog erica i really
appreciate it you are
one of the most talented individuals
i've ever known thank you for being you
and thank you this is very generous to
you thank you
and what's os frog and what the [ __ ]
does os frog mean
or is it like our i know our computer
doesn't have this computer doesn't have
the most up-to-date emojis so maybe
there was like a
oh that's probably it yeah sometimes
it'll put code in instead
and uh thank you erica again and thank
you eric horseman thank you both
seriously that means a lot
seriously um and flev doran uh
thank you flev happy birthday greg been
following guys since late 2016 and it's
a great feeling having such wonderful
people with whom i can share my passions
and favorite things
directly or undirectly have a great 30th
keep being your awesome self
never change freeze at this moment never
change
even if you start even if there's like
bad things in you even if there's
don't change those because you will lose
the good if you change the bad
even if you find out new and updated
it's about balance man
don't change and sticking to it god damn
right i'm a virgo
um yeah well thank you flef that means a
lot
and i love the relatability seriously
flavius i like your platform id
that means a lot thank you oh goodness
oh wow we got some super chats to catch
up on so we got percy we got tariq all
right we got saul next hey
soul cove hey soul nice to see you how's
it going
happy birthday greg you the best and hi
john
hi guys you do not want to address
john i have this video today i'm here i
think i'm telling you
he's gonna get cancelled they know my
name
for not being john why did you why don't
you just tell them what you did
john just tell me you're gonna throw me
that trump just just tell them nothing
tell them what you did tell them why
you're gonna live up to this tell them
why you're
tell them why you're being canceled it's
because i jumped in and started reading
your birthday
super chat that's why you're being
canceled yeah
i was totally inconsiderate look john
people will forgive you as long as you
own up to your mistakes now tell them
the truth
i i i accidentally whoa whoa john wait
no that's not ruined the documentary now
i don't wanna i don't wanna yeah spoil
it
you know this is my last chance to have
five minutes of fame
i'd like to apologize to john on camera
i don't know why this turned into my
reoccurring [ __ ]
it's okay it happens to me throughout my
life
oh god it's john's fault um thank you
and i'm seeing so many sweet comments
that keep coming in throughout the chat
i really appreciate it thank you guys
os frog was a typo there we go
it's okay um all right uh terrible thank
you sulgovan
derek brown happy birthday greg thank
you derek
appreciate it buddy you got a very
fascinating can we zoom in on that oh
yeah but you bet i i think
oh no we can't oh damn what no you uh
click it you kind of look like a pixar
character
but that's a humanoid right yeah well it
picks our characters
yeah just just look like people i mean
there are certain people that have
there are certain people and and i think
and it's cool like everybody
i think knows somebody who looks like an
animated character a little bit you know
who has yeah that's true has like very
striking features just in this live
stream really someone said like a young
adam sandler from eight crazy nights
which you
absolutely do thank you guys whoa
john john we can we can look at it we
can look at it now
we can look at it we got this we got
this
there's there he is yes he kind of looks
like a pixar character yeah i like your
look
one of those youtubers you you don't
know if you could trust
that i'm gonna go out on a limb i'm
gonna trust eric because he can cheer
you to this live stream
yeah that's that's a sign of character
by the way we're gearing up to be
covering the boys this week so keep a
lookout
ah boys chase gardner chase
thank you chase i love how big my logan
in the chat said
control plus to zoom in can you imagine
if we got this far in youtube
not know and we did not know like whoa
you can you can zoom in
what else can you zoom in on i'm gonna
make you fun of you dude i tried i was
actually
trying i'm sure that's what you actually
thought i was trying to do
and we had another window that wasn't
working yeah um
chase gardner happy birthday
have you guys played the new avengers
game it's out this week just beat it
um what has been your favorite birthday
present or movie on your birthday
um i haven't played the new avengers
game yet uh it did just come out right
yeah i haven't played it yet
yeah uh my favorite movie on my
favorite birthday present that's really
hard to decide
anything my girlfriend's got on me that
i'll just say that say my ass
hopefully it gets me late at night you
know what i mean sex
that's what i'm talking about oh that
what that was about
that's what getting laid means i was
lost
i was in hawaii favorite movie on my
birthday uh
tenet ted it's my favorite movie on my
birthday
so your favorite yeah like birthday
release yeah
i don't i don't know i mean so this time
of year is usually a terrible month to
release a birthday
i mean to release to release a movie
it's usually a terrible month
september movies rarely do well
september is the january
of the oscar season i guess yeah i mean
it's it
unless you're like it chapter two or
something but generally speaking
yeah unless you're the one movie here to
get us excited for halloween
yeah see 10 it's not playing near us
it's playing like
a a three hour trip a three to four hour
trip away
you know what would be three to four
hour trip back yeah
i wish they would do like an imax
drive-in if they had
a drive-in that could could handle that
and have
some kind of like i don't know i don't
know how you would do like a stadium
parking arrangement but
actually i think an imax driving would
be terrible john
can you imagine have us in your car and
look that [ __ ] window
and like i guess it's his head's so up
up
up there that's fair
i mean maybe you could have like an imax
projection quality but i don't think you
could do like an
imac screen of tenant but what if you
had the right parking space
just like yeah you're that one lucky
[ __ ] who gets
hey you are the one lucky [ __ ]
who gets the one chair at the theater
that's that's the specific chair
ah sir you saw a tenant i haven't seen
antennae yet oh
have you listened to any reviews or are
you like plugging your ears
i've listened to some reviews okay
here's what everyone's non-spoiler
review of tenant is
i can't get into it or else it would
spoil the movie for you so i
i'll listen to anyone's non-spoiler
because apparently you can't talk about
tenant without spoiling the film
cool i'm down i've even heard a couple
like i can't really talk about the
characters because i'll spoil the movie
like damn you can't even talk about the
characters
hey i mean that's that good good i'm
excited bizarre
yeah that's what christopher nolan he's
gotta he's gotta have something special
going on
kevin cruz is saying happy birthday greg
time to get wild
oh yeah time to get well let's go in the
streets take off the mask and coffee
people's faces today baby
let's run through a grocery store yeah
get up in everyone's grill
let's go high five random people thank
you kevin cruz
louis bridge saying happy birthday greg
welcome to the 30s have a great time
well i've taken this bridge to the 30s
i appreciate that lewis it's very sweet
of you homie heck yeah
copyright claimed copyright claim
saying chadwick bozeman passed away at
the age of 43 if the police don't get
you
maybe cancer will i mean
that's that's a heavy one that's a heavy
comment that's some heavy commentary but
chadwick boseman man i'm gonna take this
away for a minute
but chadwick boseman that was like the
main topic of conversation in my
personal life
for like many days after that
um yeah that
there uh someone told me in a
someone told i mean a comment recently
that they're re-re
oh it was cameron french they're
re-releasing 42 at some drive-ins out
here so if you're
in california and i think there's gonna
be some theaters where they're gonna be
re-releasing 42 so um if you
don't own it or haven't rented it or
whatever if you want to watch in the
theaters
go do that man because it's
[ __ ] chadwick man i knew a couple
people who knew him i got to talk to
recently and uh yeah they were it was it
was not
it was pretty surprising to hear from
like their i don't want to reveal their
perspective
obviously and they'd really love the guy
uh but it's uh
god damn shame man yeah
cancer sucks but
back to your birthday saturday night out
of that man
i like but i i feel like you know if
we're gonna talk about him
gotta take away this for a second and
just get a little bit get a little bit
real
let's hear about it um corbin thank you
corbin
saying happy birthday you guys rock
appreciate your videos
thank you well we're happy to do the
videos man
it's all i i feel like it's been a lot
of yes big mo logan amc's
re-releasing 42. uh
where's corbin corbin uh thank you
i i've i've found rece especially in the
month of august
i don't know it's been something that's
been really reigning and really fun
about filming again as of late
bye erica it's okay you can't stay
there's been something that's been like
in the past month that has just been
like
so much more fun to film again i don't
really know what it is i kicked in
but i feel like you guys have been
feeling it too lately so i appreciate
everyone who's been here and it's been a
long time since i've done a live stream
mark leach happy day birth are any goals
for this next decade
well i'm hoping in the next
year i can't go too much in detail i've
teased it a little bit here and there
over the past like year and a half um
but having little bits of progress
with a certain screenplay that i wrote
and we're like
on the i don't want to talk too much
about cause i want to get like tell them
everything people are asking me a [ __ ]
ton of questions
read the outline i don't want too many
people to be like
let's read the script you mention this
thing where is it i'm like
first screenplay it takes forever to
sell um but
we're like so close so close
and i'm hoping i'm hoping that within
the next year
i can there's something on imdb pro
about it that it's in the it's in
development i am
be pro so i don't i feel like i could
talk a little bit more about it since
we're so close to finally getting this
in production
um but there's something special that
i've been working on for the past few
years and
my main goal is to get at least one
script sold
if i get one strip so i think i could be
even fine
with all the scripts i've written like
one script i'd be like yeah i'm cool
yeah and then the rest will just release
online here you guys go
take them in once you've done it the
once then you you know you have the
experience you know you could probably
do it again
and then you know yeah you're in a whole
other little plane of reality
ah all right let's go and back into it
here
a whole new world uh but thank you mark
leach thanks the question movie couple
appreciate the sticker look how cute
this thing is
got me a grilled cheese taco bell
burrito oh
look at that with black beans they don't
eat meat
wow yeah if you guys haven't had these
these are delicious
bean and cheese my friends i cannot eat
this on the stream or else i will crash
there's like 3 000 calories in there
but it is so delicious
sending love to the movie couple too i
was really sad about falcore
what do you mean what happened with the
movie couple no they lost their dog
what yeah falcoris oh i didn't know
about that i'll message her
yeah much love oh wendy yeah
and dustin wendy industry
sorry sorry dustin i i just know wendy a
little bit better
um jarrett pelkey thank you jared
oh wow thank you so much dude what is
that sticker what's that little guy
saying let's let's zoom in
john what you want to do is hit control
wait wait
so i control alt delete okay gotcha
thanks for being you oh thank you jared
little dude looking looking
at itself in the mirror nine nine times
out of ten i associate people with the
name
jared as probably a guy i shouldn't
trust but
jared i i'm gonna trust you today buddy
and then pj is saying happy birthday
greg i'm here
pandemic jokes here could have missed
this live stream since
we love all cinematic universes what are
you guys looking forward to most from dc
and marvel in the next few years [ __ ]
yeah
this is a question i've been waiting to
talk about today yes all right
so well i'm gonna stick a little bit
more dc i'm not gonna lie
all right i am not looking forward
tomorrow i'm not looking forward to
marvel at all
i have no interest in what they're doing
um
you know they were supposed to start
shooting black panther in february
that's when they're supposed to start
shooting black panther too isn't that
crazy this past february
no no or this is coming this coming
february gearing to shoot up
and uh because i know someone who is
going to be working on the production
for that
and yeah they're supposed to start
shooting in february oh boy
um jesus so
yeah marvel uh i mean uh marvel's been
killing it alongside for dc though
is uh for dc they are
really because okay let's take
a step back there's mcu which started
this trend of everyone trying to launch
these cinematic universes
that were all connected in a linear way
and
uh what the dc what the dc universe is
the what they're doing what i'm excited
about is they really
are starting to open up the doors of
multiple dimensions multiple universes
that are still existing so like the way
i viewed it
is you have the multiverses with inside
the dc
galaxy so there's like the galaxy and
then there's this multiverse of a whole
bunch of movies and shows
and what i'm really hoping for because
doom patrol is like
one of my absolute favorite dc things
ever to come out of any of the
live-action medium associated with dc
and i am hoping the movies can
eventually get to the point where they
can be as
[ __ ] weird and bizarre and
difficult to describe as doom patrol is
it's a much harder pitch for
for a movie but i'm hoping dc can get
there but
in terms of what we're getting now i'm
excited for
the amount of variety that dc is
offering us
you know it's kind of crazy to be in a
day and age where
you can accept that you're going to see
a a flash movie where there's going to
be two batman in there
and not be at all weirded out or
confused or find it strange that there's
also this robert pattinson batman movie
coming out yeah
and then you're getting a snyder cut
film as well i think i think it's great
and i feel like
what dc's been doing that's
exceptionally awesome is they
have really learned how to listen to
their fans and i feel like they've
gotten really good at connecting with
their fans
uh and a way to satisfy them and give
them some
genuine surprises so yeah i would say
that um
dc is [ __ ] killing it man and uh
yeah they're they're the batman's the
one i'm most looking forward to then the
snyder cut
yeah they seem like they're they're
really embracing their potential for
variety and
the fact that they have so many
different areas of ground they can break
like i'm just excited to see dc take
advantage of their newfound confidence
and yeah
all the different things at their
disposal because of their commitment to
this
level of multiverse and multi cinematic
styles and whatnot and then for marvel
i'm just looking forward to them
uh truly doing something to mix
themselves
up yeah that we've had you know this
complete arc
but i would also say man just if you
guys
haven't started watching uh
if you guys haven't started watching
sorry big look if you guys haven't
started watching doom patrol
please watch doom patrol please watch it
you will not regret it it is so
worth it such a bizarre show um but
easily one of my favorites to come out
of dc
um yeah yeah that's what i'd say oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah so synthetic
thanks fantamic jones
yeah what's up ethan holgate thanks
buddy ethan
thank you dude oh that's so cool this is
what greg looks like every day
yeah just cool and chill phoenix495 says
whoa
had a check you were also born on labor
day me too
i always think that cool is it not
another
question before youtube what was your
dream job
to be born on labor day to be born on
labor day
i already got to be a moderator for a
youtuber's livestream
my uh oh you can watch doom patrol i
think it's on the dc universe app but
i watch on hbo max i'm sorry if you're
in a country that doesn't offer hbo max
but that's where i watch it or you know
download it somewhere
i won't say where but uh piracy my
my dream job before youtube
i've always wanted to get into
filmmaking and and youtube was always
meant to be the
the the step in between getting into
writing first and i'm
so i'm just really trying i'm so close
it's something so close i'm on the like
on the cusp of it
like i've had people who are involved
were like hey congratulations dude and
i'm like
don't say it yet not until we're like
actually about
to do it yeah not until it's on dvd
uh yeah it's straight to dvd movie guys
that's what my big dream is
video on demand um
my dream i actually really wanted to be
a firefighter
uh that was my a dream job of mine when
i was younger at
anything outside of film it was i wanted
to be a firefighter
i remember one time we went to a
firefighting station yeah and i just
stopped in there i'm like hey can i try
on the
they just let me try it on it was a
really fun time um yeah
i used to want to be a firefighter and
uh and nowadays it seems like to be the
most terrifying job
yeah you literally just been on fire for
like three weeks now
you will see this guys parts of the year
did you have a dream job that was not
filmed it was music
film or music did you have a job that
was traditional
john opening a restaurant you just
wanted to open a restaurant
i just wanted to cut the ribbon call it
a day
being a chef having a restaurant cooking
for people
oh yeah that was a little yeah
you know when we were younger he used to
crash at john's place and the entire
time we lived together he never did this
which blows my mind
he used to make like [ __ ]
um oh the pancake he would make like
we'd make john would make pancakes in
the morning we'd be there's like fourth
grade fourth or fifth grade he'd make
pancakes in the morning yeah cause i'd
eat breakfast back then
and then he for some reason he'd make
like
40 i'm not i am not joking this is not
some exaggeration joke
he'd make around 30 to 40 pancakes
yeah because at the time i obviously
have to refrigerate majority of them
yeah
at the time i wasn't very good at the uh
the proportionate math of cutting down
like of doing a recipe and a half i was
like one's not gonna be enough
i better make two batches so he would
take like
a very long time to make the pancakes
because he was making so many pancakes
yeah
yeah i could probably do a more compact
batch now
yeah i don't know what your deal was
john you know i
i just told you and not one time in the
amount of time we were living together
she ever bought her to whip up a batch
of 40 pancakes
hey if you ever want pancakes again i
will what the [ __ ] dude
i will happily make you some people let
me down john i know you let me down
that's what i'm here for
all right guys let you down and not make
pancakes let's see here
all right
how long have we been friends john since
third grade so like
20 something years it's a long time
that's why i'm canceling john you guys
figured it out today
because he had certain promises that he
never lived up to
i'm gonna lowball it and say we've known
each other for yet 22 23 years
something like that good amount of time
yeah um do i
do we think that batman will be r-rated
no
you know it's weird it was funny about
the batman
i feel like some people are already sick
of talking about it and it's one of
those upcoming films
that gets i've experienced this from
most movies i've noticed that every time
i've started talking about the batman
some viewers have dipped every single
time so i feel like some people are
already sick of
talking about it but it's one of those
random upcoming movies that
it's few and far between sometimes i get
to a point pretty early i'm like okay i
don't wanna keep talking about this
right now can we take a break from
talking about this
yeah i don't know for some reason the
batman's the one moving i'm like yeah i
don't mind i don't mind
let's talk about it yeah because it's
like a shanghai
drought oh my god something incredible
to look forward to i don't think it'll
be rated r
but uh i feel like matt reeves
especially after watching dawn of the
planet of the apes and warfare planet
and let me i think let me in was pg-13
no no that was our
no yeah matt reeves is really good at
making films that feel like they should
be rated r
but you get why they're not rated hard
yeah
they're they're not explicit enough to
get there so you can still pg-13 it but
they have that tone that's a little
heavier they have this like menacing
grit and mood that could in that like
environment
that can feel like is this movie written
or oh it's not
you know actions feel like they have a
toll in his movies
like the the emotional effect and the
impact of the violence especially that
he portrays in his movies
have this r rated vibe to them but i
don't think the movie will be rated r
but if it is that would be pretty
awesome
i feel people take i mean especially for
the fact that it [ __ ] like looks like
the movie seven
you kind of get the vibe though like it
kind of looks like it has to be rated r
it would be cool though because think of
it too they could i
i don't know exactly but i feel like the
first r-rated big batman movie would be
enough to bring people in the same way
yeah and for joker you know
uh hey audi uh odd bike
it's your birthday too sorry to get your
name right no i butchered that buddy
sorry
um let's see here and yes homie is a
40 pancakes what are these suicide squad
leaks that people are talking about and
yes we're going to be watching
uh the boys season two starting at this
weekend
and uh we'll be putting up reactions for
it i didn't know until a couple days ago
that it's three episodes this weekend
then it goes to weekly
which honestly is a relief because
covering umbrella academy
i'm not used to because there are some
some reaction channels
where all they do are the tv reactions
and then they put full links on watch
along and we got all this like exclusive
content on patreon
and then we try to keep up with like
different youtube videos daily
and then covering umbrella academy was
like an extra six to eight hours a day
for me which was really fun rewarding
and it really paid off in a lot of ways
and uh i enjoyed the experience but yeah
i didn't really sleep much in like for
like three straight because then dc
fandom was two days later
so uh yeah covering that uh because
because the fact that it was netflix i
was like i gotta get this out every
other day because people are gonna lose
interest fast
so the fact that the boys is weak
that's a stress relief
yeah that makes uh that makes a much
bigger difference in terms of like uh
not having to worry so much about
hurrying the videos you know
also hey morgan thank you for
acknowledging the microphone quality
thanks for being not as the camera
quality
let's see here um all right okay
john has watched the boy season one have
all of it it was delightful
congratulations john you're not canceled
anymore thank you cara bell
yeah i watched the boys season one and i
watched the ultimate edition of bvs so
i'm i'm
doing i'm i'm just done some stuff i'm
climbing up the hill
of of things i should have already seen
where is the f [ __ ] um god damn it
where's the uh i can't guys i'll make
the pancakes
i promise where's the [ __ ] pancake
show where's the pancake we're sitting
here we've been talking about it for
like 10 minutes now you could have been
making them this whole time
thank you for saying happy birthday
heroes float oh yeah let's catch up a
little bit here
yeah let's go make a little bit of this
john do the thing you do let's go over
to the stream lab
zen what are you doing what do you think
everybody's been here for the stream
yeah comment below if you're excited for
them to recut the godfather three
are they really coppola is apparently
going to restore
and re-cut the godfather through why
i'm not sure you should ask why is he
doing that
i don't know i write it on collider this
afternoon that's messed up
why what if it makes it better
what if it won't nothing nothing can
what what alternate takes are there for
his daughter's performance
there's no way they could be fed oh i'm
so happy like
every line sophia coppola had in
godfather 3 was awful there's no way
that could be better
um that's impossible oh he's going to do
it you never know
maybe that's impossible what if they get
a new score and it changes everything
jesus christ all right [ __ ] landon smith
i think homelander is a great role model
everyone should be like homelander from
the boys yeah
uh homelander is is is incredibly
unsettling to me and in fact
that airplane sequence with him that was
one of the most
like i don't i've never quite felt that
way watching an episode of tv i was like
i wanted to cry it was so horrifically
ugly
oh man i love that scene it's a great
scene but it's like it's oh
when the people he's trying to keep the
people on the plane and he goes
a [ __ ] laser laser yeah oh god
oh damn the boys can't wait for the
season yeah
i heard season two is amazing i'm
excited
um how is it nevermind all right
donkey where's my cheesecake what a
great great username dude thank you
you and tongue punch fartbox need to
meet up where's my
hi hi thank you for your contribution
here dude do you
like music like alternative rock punk
pop punk
emo if you do what is your favorite band
artist well i would say between the
three easily it's alternative rock
um my favorite my two favorite bands of
all time
are red hot chili peppers easily number
one and second behind them would be
france ferdinand
who's a little bit not exactly
alternative a little bit like pop
rock or something i don't know what
category they're like alternative rock a
little bit of like
there's like european pop in there in
there
and yeah yeah you know it's a little bit
of new wave i would say
uh those are my two like alternative
rocks most likely my favorite
genre but i'm also kind of really into
like
some of that dark country like outlaw
country stuff
dark southern vibe yeah or i don't know
barnes courtney doesn't quite
qualify in there like my favorite
beyonce song
is daddy lessons which is like a a
country song
yeah um but it's got a bit of that dark
undertone to it so
weirdly it's kind of that but yeah i
would say i mean chili peppers
and france fernand are easily my top two
favorite bands
um i mean yeah of these three genres i
would say the alternative rock is
probably my favorite although there's
there have been pop punk and emo bands
definitely over the years that i've
followed probably the most
prolific of them being fallout boy
they've kind of shed some of these
genres
or at least crashed a whole bunch of
other things into them now
um but yeah i mean like my favorite
groups are like queens of the stone age
gorillas franz ferdinand's one of them
uh
silver sun pickups i mean but guys let's
face it the best song of the year
i like some green day the best new song
of the year is easily
wet ass [ __ ] whap man yeah
whether you heard it on purpose or by
accident you can't deny that song
put some macaroni in a pot for that
wet ass [ __ ] baby
we're singing we're singing cardi b
singing that wet ass [ __ ] singing megan
the stallion right now
i wish you all could have heard that
whoa i wish you guys you guys couldn't
hear that on the mic
park that big mac truck in the same
garage and if you guys want to laugh
this is the only time i'm ever going to
promote ben shapiro
oh my god yes yes go
find it did you see ben shapiro's where
he listened to it by accident
i've seen him clip he's
she clearly has a gynecological
condition
it is so funny i was
bursting this guy just doesn't get it
he was so sincere it was hilarious and
then my favorite
youtube reaction of that is um damn
who's the guy
i love this guy i watched so many of his
videos uh i'm blaking on his name
which guy what is it the one him i'm
dante and the other guy are the two
music reactors i watch live shack
no live shack yeah uh no live shacks
reaction of it so funny
oh yes but yes you must
you must increase your bust there's one
ben shapiro thing in the whole world
you'll ever hear me recommend it is
watching him
fail to understand wet ass [ __ ]
oh oh do yourself cause everyone's
lifestyle that's clearly never aroused
his wife before
yeah it's painful when it's that clear
when it's that like oh wow
i'm sorry for the both of you for
waiting for the reason it's so
funny so funny
what some 41. wait no daddy lessons live
with dixie chicks
they do that live together holy [ __ ]
cool man we should do it
we should do a live stream if we're
talking about music you know
actually through stream labs or obs or
something it might be easier to do the
kind of music video reactions where we
just pause
stuff so you know we could that's true
it's possible we can look further into
it
you know who i just when i just heard
for the first time this last christmas
just to cap off donkey's question is uh
i just heard the black parade the album
for the first time because when it came
out
that i missed i was just wasn't there
for that i wasn't about it i the lead
single turned me off
but uh that's a that's a pretty prolific
like emo pop punk alternative album so
yeah
there's some good stuff in that category
and uh someone in the chat can remember
who right now was asking about the
harley quinn show
almost done with season two at this
point um
it's an interesting experience with the
show because
there's there's a there's a certain show
that my girlfriend's been showing me
which i'm
[ __ ] in love with um but i don't want
to say it because i don't want anyone to
spoil something for me
so this show i've been watching and then
this other show
that we've been watching is harley quinn
and then she wanted to watch harley
quinn
i was like all right cool let's start it
and i wasn't that into it
and then around episode five i really
started getting into harley quinn
and she started losing interest in it
and that's what she kind of just
watches it because i want to watch it
and she's not really that into the show
but i
really think that harley quinn shows i i
i think it's really funny um what like
if you could sum up what you like about
it in a couple seconds
well the show was a full-on comedy yeah
and i didn't realize
how a how hard our harley quinn the
dc anime show was gonna be i didn't
realize how hard r was gonna be
so wait is she's like swearing and [ __ ]
like there's like [ __ ] bombs the whole
time yeah there's like a whole bunch of
f words
it's very violent and uh it's very
self-aware
and it does it rides a great line at
making fun of its source material with
all these characters at the same time
letting them be actual characters
existing in this world
um bane is hilarious
isn't ron funches king shark yeah
and uh kite man i didn't know kai man
was a character but kite man
he's my favorite he's my absolute
favorite i love
the joker i love the harley quinn and
ivy
dynamic um so yeah i i love uh
uh i love the show i think i think it's
great batman's hilarious
gordon is funny it's a really funny
really funny show um and i personally
really like it so yeah then i'll have to
shrek it out
this other show i'm watching well once
i'm at a comfortable point to tell
everyone what i'm watching
it's pretty addicting it really is what
could it be
come on man oh you wouldn't know i think
it needs to know something
who needs to don't give it away there's
only one show and i don't think it would
be like such a big deal but yeah i don't
know
all right uh john please please change
the topic
actually somebody in the chat said
something uh kobakai uh yeah
we i i covered season two on the patreon
but we did we didn't do it on youtube
so yeah we might do season three though
my two season three netflix now
um mimi m thank you
or not or me me probably me me em happy
birthday to charlie sheen
and redfoo one half of the musical duel
lmfao
no way it's his birthday today too red
foo isn't he related to so isn't he like
quincy jones's other
other so that people can see the top of
the comment
question if you can have a perfect meal
appetizer main course and dessert what
would you get the restaurant can make
whatever you want i stole the question
from the podcast off menu
all right here we go here's what i would
get oh all right
perfect meal so the the appetizer
would be mozzarella cheese sticks from
from denny's because i don't know why i
think they're just the best
so danny's mozzarella cheese sticks
comfort food
uh the main course would have to be
this grilled cheese burrito with also
um a large cheese pizza from my favorite
restaurant in tarzana uh favorite pizza
place in tarzana california
called milanos highly recommend it and
then
uh for dessert i would go to
baskin robbins to get their dark
chocolate vegan ice cream
yeah that's what it would be john what
about you oh dude all right
all right let's see appetizer
it's an anime show by the way i was
tensing out
okay yeah yeah yeah i i think that was
that would have been my guess but i
can't draw the title to mine
um okay so appetizer um
let me get like a crab cake i think that
would be cool
uh main course yeah some kind of
you're gonna tell them john oh goodness
uh make horses
[ __ ] do i get a cocktail with this or
not
no no john that's great there's there's
lots of yeah
john's best meal would be something he
makes
i would love to make i like making we
were living together it was tacos
yeah tacos every night well yeah because
it became like a really easy way of like
oh i
i know i can like easily proportion out
the ingredients and i just buy the
ingredients all the time and like it's
all the proteins that i need
yeah oh i can't wait to eat this thing
the thing you you forget about
is that like oh man cooking a variety of
things takes time and resources yeah it
does man
thank you to everyone who's just
randomly jumping in here right now and
saying happy birthday means a lot
it does thank you to everyone who's been
here this entire time thank you
everyone's been here this
entire time barry gordy there you go the
founder of motown records barry gordy jr
all right guys well we're gonna go
through the
oh wow there's some super chats you're
totally behind us
yeah we're gonna go through the the
final round of these but then we wanted
to stick to the live stream chat and
gotta wrap it up
to uh a little bit of a birthday dinner
with my girlfriend oh
that's cool of you guys john please what
you cannot watch us i want cannot watch
olivia and i doing
you can't stop me john can you hold down
my birthday stream for a minute yeah
totally and then because i'm going to
get some ice packs for us yeah cause it
is
lazy hot in here oh oh my god you're
dying your hair
yeah whatever you need yo i'm gonna get
some ice packs really fast
it's burning hot it is a little bit hot
yeah
a little bit it's blazing we can
theoretically have a fan on because of
these mics
john hold the fork down john is gonna
stay and entertain you guys while greg
goes and gets us
i did watch our episode from my cat from
hell how'd you come across
um someone uploaded it on youtube
oh no and olivia and i
randomly started watching it we really
want to watch like the opening
but then we started laughing at their
editing of the dramatization of [ __ ]
it's uh we're like because though
the way that the way they did the story
of my cat from hell was like
olivia and greg are on the brink of doom
unless they solve their cat problems and
i was like this [ __ ] is so funny we
gotta watch the rest of this
oh goody oh good all right um i'm gonna
get some ice packs yeah man
john i will be here john my john
be nice to john as i step out for a
minute hi guys yeah
treat me with care handle with care
grave encounters i have seen parts of
grave encounters that's like a found
footage movie right i fell asleep
but not because it was bad i was tired
when i started watching it john is the
third wheel perpetually
you know i've been a third wheel in so
many situations in my life but it's okay
uh even though it's there's always a
residual awkward i feel like every third
wheel scenario has a different
proportionality of awkwardness and i
feel like uh
i've i've been able to get into the
non-awkward third wheel every now and
again
vegan king that's what uh greg needs to
get
tattooed thwipster what's little baby's
ice cream is that
is that like the wrapper or is that just
like a brand of ice cream
talking about bands lisa you're fair ooh
muse radiohead interval better than ezra
editors we are scientists arctic monkeys
stereophonics and lots of
bollywood music ay that's a cool one to
tack on
at the end there one of these things is
not like the others but i like uh
your i like i like that you're checking
on me over
uh i like a lot of those bands it's good
i feel like
thinking back on that emo question i
wish i knew more deep cuts
that's [ __ ] and we're back and we're
back all right john
we got this first oh let's refresh so
that we don't miss a beat
let's oh and while we're refreshing i'm
just gonna scroll down on collider here
see the godfather part three to receive
a complete restoration re-edit a new
title why
why are you even trying look at that
look it's not going to be better
it is going to be so vehicle so much it
won't be
better it's going to be great now it's
not going to work
this is this is the new thing is we're
gonna take a failed sequel and just
recut it
and and instead of doing i appreciate
everyone who's been contributing in this
in this
like it really does mean a hell of a lot
okay
especially with the fact that like the
last few videos
on youtube are just like not like
demonetized right
yeah so thank you guys so your support
really does mean a lot right now
all right phoenix 49.5 uh no if you did
that one yeah it was the last okay yeah
sarah campbell thank you thank you so
much yeah
i thought you were a different sarah
campbell when i first saw your name but
then i saw a closer look at your photo i
was like that's a different sarah
campbell
so thank you sarah campbell yeah
thank you you know what sarah was
thinking i know i was just i was
choosing in that moment not to say my
comments
yeah too revealing but then i was like
oh never mind that's a different one but
thank you sarah
you're usually in our streams i really
appreciate it um j-tron
happy birthday dude i love you guys
enjoy your day thank you jay tron love
you too buddy appreciate it very much so
for sharing in the joy mr vaijuu
mr raju happy birthday man welcome to
the dirty 30 just remember to stretch
before everything now
well you guys don't know this but i'm a
pretty big stretcher yeah you've done
the splits on this very live stream
segment before i love to stretch
it's my one of my favorite things
stretching is is a great activity it
really is it just
feels good yeah i feel more relaxed the
next day
especially when you're like doing
reactions it's weird because
you want to feel loose and like the
freedom to express yourself
dude and then to express with your body
language i feel like stretching is
uh is a really great feeling yeah one of
my favorite things to do with the
knights
jerk off is stretch jerk off
and then continue stretching
got a chirp wheel i gotta tell ya for my
back it's like a foam roller but it's
more narrow and it's got like a thing
carved out for your spine
and uh in terms of like a means of
stretching and massaging
ah it's wow it's great for your back go
grab it
this is not a sponsored video no it's
not oh brendan v
brandon v thank you so much dude i hope
you're feeling better
happy birthday to you too i love you
buddy
i hope you're feeling i hope things have
been a little bit better for you as of
late but i really do appreciate that
brad
david gandonader give your shattered in
the bond video today buddy
david said any thoughts thank you david
any thoughts on post craig bond
nttd looks dope and a great send-off for
craig
what oh no time to die
i thought he was saying nttd is like
some actor
yeah that is gonna be like a great
replacement for james bond
um yeah i mean i think no time to die
looks great
but i i think it all depends on the the
weird thing about
no one's i don't think most people think
this is gonna happen
i don't even actually believe they'll go
there
yet i feel like there's a possibility
this could be the bond movie where they
they kill him off
and then they just start again they're
like we're gonna pick this off from the
t
dalton standpoint well you know what's
funny is i i was all the other bot
movies don't count
we're starting from this timothy dalton
movie right now
now this is the actual candidate this is
the actual candidate james bond from
your own house
this is a funny thing to me though is is
uh is is uh
i don't know what i was gonna say it's
great it's great i had a point it was
totally there on this live stream today
john
no no i don't know how to move forward
with with i can see them killing him off
ye potentially if they want to do
something bold but that's what it was i
was watching a video about
just his bond movies and they somebody
pointed out and i never
fully clicked with this but that you
know in skyfall he goes to that
tombstone and it confirms that his
real name is is james bond and james
bond is not a name that is passed along
as an alias
and so like that kind of cements the
character to this guy
um so in a way to continue i could see
it being sort of appropriate to kill him
off
true you know i think i think i mean i
feel like you could just
contin start again and that would just
go to support the theory again that just
like double 07 james bond it's just
another agent who's taking on the mantle
because i think if you were to tell
people right now lashawna lynch is
taking over
uproar right oh my god but
what if what if this could be the rare
case
where no time to die comes out the
shauna lynch is so great
before they ever say she's taking over
the franchise which is so great people
are like
man she should take over the french like
fans are opting for that
yeah that would be awesome that would be
cool i'm very curious to to hear what
people generally want moving forward
because there's
been oh joaquin i can read your ch i
could read yours
oh don't worry walking i see it all
walking all right sorry
no no it's okay like i don't know
exactly what people
want moving forward and i know that the
some of the
craig movie handsome white guy yeah
handsome white male
and what but what tone too and what kind
of spy thing you know james bond has
its classic elements but it also needs
to update itself and so now i'm sitting
here wondering yeah
can we do like what do you guys think
if they just if they gave us a female
james bond would you be here for it or
you of the mind that we should just
create a new character yeah you know
i i mean i'm seeing people in the chat
and ask me to do the splits my legs are
way too sore i cannot do this
i i go back and watch every live stream
until you find it because i don't
remember the last time i did it on
stretch and wank yes eric that is it
mark leach are there any
shows films you loved the first time but
ended up
hey thank you mark leach by the way
ended up hating or vice versa also my
choice of musician to meet would be
the david bowie um any shows or films i
love the
first time there's nothing i really
think of that i
loved then hated there are things i
could think of that
i i hated and then loved or
things that i loved and then upon
reviewing i was like i didn't like it as
much the second time
you know joker
i love the i love the first 30 and
bradley blood says in the chat is
probably going to set him i love the
first 30 minutes of joker and i love the
last 30 minutes but the in-between stuff
i really fluctuate there a lot um but
the first time i saw joker i loved it
but regardless joaquin phoenix is
perfect in it throughout um but i can't
really think of a movie that i
loved the first time and hated um that's
that's a thinker
once i once either one of us arrives at
that it'll like let let me know
um harrison 818 do you guys live
together if so what was the hardest
thing to deal with between you guys
well thank you harrison818 for the
contribution we don't live together
right now
but um he lives at
home and there's only a few like
if you combine me and olivia here and
then the people he lives with
that's only six people so we've only
kept it at that pretty much and then the
occasional person who comes by
who's usually informing me they've been
cover tested before coming by
so um harrison 818 the hardest thing to
deal with
between us we were living together oh
man where to start where to start
let's air it out let's air it all out
right here it all out right on on air
let's get too real with everybody yeah
it's getting way too real let's get into
the friction of our entire friendship
right here oh yeah let's go pound
bruises
um gosh i don't know
i didn't like being the main one to wake
up john for reactions
that's fine when there was like a one
early in the mornings i was usually up
prettier i'll only give a hint of one i
didn't like being the main guy
to be like john wake up everything's
already set up
i'm ready to rock or i'd be flicking on
the lights and he'd be like
i'm up my hair is already long so it's
good let's get to it
yeah that was pretty much that was that
was the main thing
it's taken yeah cracking mornings is
taking a long time
yeah i feel like you're better at it
better i'm a lot better right now
yeah even even we don't do it so much
especially without trailers to do it for
but you know even on the 5 a.m just like
driving over here is not as hard as it
used to be
yeah i just pull all nighters
i i i lay down and pretend that this two
hours is a power nap
yeah um let's see here sarah campbell's
got another question
thank you sarah what was the last tv
netflix series you watched and thought
yeah
this should have been a movie um whoa
one that should have been a movie
there's ones that i've watched from
like this should have been a show yeah
um
but one that should have been a movie a
netflix one
my tiger king tiger king way too long
too much too much footage much memeable
content
um i don't know usually when it's a show
it's
fine as a show i mean i kind of sure
could have been
shorter i kind of felt that way about
like all the season
twos of most of the marvel netflix shows
like like jessica jones season two could
have
been um oh no no yeah season three was
better than season two but jessica doing
season two could have been a movie
um but i i don't really know of a of a
netflix show that i want i mean do you
guys have one
that i might be like oh i agree with
that warrior none
i'm just gonna go out on a limb and
assume yeah i don't i'm sorry for
breaking your heart there
on the joker one bradley but yeah i
can't
really think of uh of one that was
where i was waiting i see like big mo
logan saying it in the chat right now
iron fist season two could have been a
movie but
and that's what i mean is like there's a
lot of those seasons of the marvel
like their first seasons are great but
then the the season two even though i
thought iron fist season two was a major
improvement on season one
i'm still like well a lot of those shows
could have just been a movie you know
especially punisher season two could
have definitely been a movie
haunting of see the thing is i thought
of haunting of hill house but the
problem is that
show really capitalizes on its minister
like it's not a netflix movie but the
last time i saw a movie
well no this is the reverse again we saw
the doctor sleep and i was like this
should have been a series oh no i do
yeah i've [ __ ] should have been a
netflix hell no i would have no
i much rather would have i would not
have wanted it to be a movie
i thought it was i thought that was a
near perfect series yeah
yeah yeah if they made a movie instead
i'm not saying this
not gonna lie i'm kind of concerned
about a season two
yeah it looks like it could be
repetitive well yeah that's that's i
guess to make have you seen the uh the
tease for blind yeah i watched the
trailer yeah how does it look
it looks cool all right they had a
really cool stinger this the follow-up
trailer for
no what's it called the haunting of
blind manner hunting a blind manor is
the follow-up to haunting a hill house
in case you guys don't know and
um i it looks cool and i love the last
tease the last moment of that trailer i
thought was great
but i'm kind of concerned it could be on
repeat
i feel like the trailer doesn't make it
clear enough that it's it's not related
because you've seen some of the same
actors and it looks like they're in the
same roles
yeah i'm like this trailer needs to
really clarify that this is
not the same thing you know at least
with like american horror story when you
recast
when you or when you put the act same
actors from a previous season into a new
one
they look different they put all this
crazy makeup on them and [ __ ]
and this trailer nope they look like i
got i even got confused and had to
remind myself that oh this is not the
same thing that's right they're playing
different people
but they they look exactly the same you
know look
it's the people a lot of people saying
game of thrones season eight no
no no don't make that any short big
problem
[ __ ] short that [ __ ] yeah um
harrison818 back at it happy birthday
thank you harrison thank you buddy yeah
archer pa um thank you dude
uh where'd he go where'd he go happy b
day greg
hi john i apologize for missing your
birthday live stream
yeah you missed john's birthday
livestream i don't have a question but i
hope both of you in the rejig nation are
safe
feeling okay and are staying as awesome
as their creators
well reject nation i hope you're staying
safe and being careful out there
and thank you archer pa for the very
kind words means a hell of a lot to have
you here thank you dude
mother and uh eric horstmann
thank you dude since you're reacting to
the boys please tell me also the
haunting of blind manner
also i miss doing a reaction to the new
teaser trailer too oh and happy b day
again
you know netflix gives us so many
problems there's a reason why we haven't
[ __ ] been covering some of those
netflix trailers
but uh no uh hunting a blind manor
we'll have to see where we're at at that
point but it's something
definitely i'm i'm heavily considering
because
i don't know the haunting of hill house
is such a slow show
that most of it i'm not like most of
them just like really engage
you jump occasionally it's very rare you
know it gives you a lot to talk about
afterwards but yeah as a reaction eric's
like now they'll get to my blind manner
question
after talking about it
i mean it would be cool to check or what
if we i mean we could just do streams
only or something
maybe i definitely i'm interested in the
show but
there's some shows that i'm like
there's some shows that people ask us to
react to but there there's
some of those in that camp i i honestly
prefer to just kind of watch on my own
because i know that it's one of those
shows that i'll probably really enjoy
but i won't be really reacting out loud
you know or like the reason i really
want to do umbrella
academy season two was because
when i saw season one by myself i was
very audible when i was watching it by
myself
and i was like this would be a great
show to react to
you know where as haunting of hill house
i'm pretty quiet the whole time
until a couple of moments where i'm like
oh it was scary
because it's one of those like real
deliberate like better call saul's one
of my favorite shows but i would not
want to do a reaction to it
um just go back and watch my season one
reactions with me and see how the
experiences
but we'll see you know i might i might
consider it
you know why i might consider it because
eric horseman is the one asking for it
and he's been
as the man an amazing supporter of this
channel so i might do it
just because of eric horseman heck yeah
maybe
no eric i'm reading the chat right now
no i don't want to break your heart dude
no eric no no
torchwood talk to me about it again eric
you can't have both um seriously
talk to me about it again i might i
might do it
thermonuclear thermonuclear did you
hear thank you thunder manuka dear
dwayne johnson and his family caught
covet i did hear they caught kovad but
he posted a video and he seems like he's
i don't know the covet is such a weird
situation because we can't tell for a
lot of people
what'll do to their immune system or
their bodily functions you know
and dwayne johnson i don't know it
looked fine
well i watched he might have it but he
looks fine i watched that two-minute
like twitter video he put up and i think
in that he said they were over the hump
or or like they were
you know symptomatic and [ __ ] last week
or something like that
but even even still yeah i don't know
yeah it's one of those things where i
couldn't really tell what the severity
of it was although he just said
it was one of the most challenging
things that he they had to face as a
family which i
you know believe man looks like the
patronage really want us to cover
the haunting of blind man or maybe we
should do that
we'll do a poll and we'll see if people
want us to do it how about that eric
when it's rolling around we'll see what
people say
um but i think i think dwayne johnson
will be okay
and anissa's blood is the cure to the
cover disease so i i think it'll be okay
inject yourself church chills cigar
hi greg happy birthday thank you dude
was just wondering if you're related to
adam sandler after the picture you
posted
no i wish i was because my career
pursuits would be a whole lot easier
if i had adam sandler in my life hello
there reject nation
an excuse to do it lauren mcintyre thank
you lauren mcintyre really appreciate
that thank you
this first time seeing your name thank
you so much
you lauren mark leach
uh thank you dude love the bill and ted
live stream
you did uh will you do more film
reactions also hashtag bring back greg
and john's terrible english
impersonations
we would lose so many oh yeah so ah mark
we were ending on your question no way
you're leaving now
mark uh so love
the bill and ted live streams will you
do more film reactions
maybe it depends on the film yeah i mean
that was a lot of fun
that was a real spontaneous decision the
day before yeah
like let's just do it this way and at
least i mean at least as far as things
on on
you know that vimeo go got pretty decent
views i mean
we're trying to i mean not like you know
not like youtube
there's no ads on that or anything you
know but but
the thing with um i'm trying to be a
little bit more calculated with the film
and tv reactions i want to make sure
there's something
that i know will naturally generate a
cause because a lot of the time you
don't want them to be flashes in the
panel
yeah a lot of time it can be like you're
you're trying to bring out something
because there's certain shows that
i love but i'm just not really audible
when i'm watching it by myself and it's
so if there's a show where i'm audible
by myself
um or that i know i'll be that way then
that makes for the perfect show to do
reaction to
because capturing that genuine energy is
the most important thing i think for
doing reactions for sure is capturing
the sincerity
of the uh the the natural things that
would come out of you when watching it
god you sound like a professional
there's like a show called naruto that
i'm telling you
landon smith thank you dude landon happy
birthday greg what kind of role would
you like to see jensen ackles
in the boy season three good or bad guy
powers no powers love to hear your guys
thoughts on this
i would absolutely i mean from from the
point i'm at
in in in uh supernatural i would want
him to have
super powers and i'd want her to be a
bad guy
um because on the fact the supernatural
he doesn't have superpowers and he's a
good guy so i think it would be great to
watch him
play a guy with superpowers and be a bad
guy i think would be great
i don't know if homelander will stick
around after season two but if he's in
some way a supplement for him
that'd be pretty sick i love that yeah
i'm looking forward to whatever i think
yeah just because it would be so cool to
see him play a
different kind of character i would go
right or at least if not
evil sort of like a chaotic neutral
character
who you don't know really like his
allegiance has changed yeah
yeah a wild card no i said yeah we're
gonna be doing season two with the boys
because yeah i saw season one of the
boys and i was like [ __ ]
whole time so yeah now we got people
talking about torchwood
oh no oh yeah let's get through doctor
thank you to everyone who's coming in
here and saying happy birthday right now
thank you
um thermonuclear thank you again happy
birthday greg stay song and stay safe
well thank you dude
appreciate that katie anne happy
birthday greg
what villain would you fight oh thank
you katie
what villain would i fight
any villain i'd want to fight i'd want
to fight
ivan drago
to avenge the death of creed about the
creed i was gonna say
creed two like no no no i don't want to
fight ivan dragon before rocky iv oh
that's good
or i'd want to fight francis ford
coppola for thinking he could uh [ __ ]
make a good godfather
that's not going to happen we have no
faith
i have no faith in that when was the
last time he made a critically lauded
movie he can do it it's been many years
it's been a minute
maybe this will bring him back redoing
another version of apocalypse now is not
not the thing to do and sandler is a
virgo too katie and saying that the chat
look
oh dude maybe you have the same birthday
[ __ ] hmm
um tariq allen lastly who would you
thank you terry who would you work for
christopher nolan james cameron
tarantino or kubrick
mine is christopher nolan who did
inception i don't i know who christopher
owens um
i'd be quentin tarantino because stanley
kubrick sounds like he was a little too
difficult to work for that
sounds like it would hurt emotionally to
do that and
nolan um uh i feel like would be great
from like
if i wanted to shadow a director i would
be nolan
but tarantino i feel like to work for
him assuming you're talking about like
acting
for in some way or writing with uh
i feel like uh he gonna let you do that
i feel like you would really get a great
experience especially from an actor's
standpoint of being directed by a guy
like him
yeah yeah i would agree i think
tarantino would be the most like because
you just
there's a certain level of like i don't
know what i'm gonna get like yeah
it could be anything it could be a crazy
character or whatever and even if it's
small just
just i know that usually everything is
kind of rich in those movies yeah
nolan would be my second choice just
because i've heard like his sets are
pretty
nice to be on like it's a pretty
pleasant vibe it's very accepting and
also yeah like his craft
i just feel like tarantino might be more
fun true set to to
geek out on um so yeah
and i want to change my question my
answer from the villain one back
to uh i want to take b williams uh i
want to fight bvs as lex luthor
because he seems like he'd be easier to
beat yeah you could uh in a fist cup
yeah he could punch him ooh breaking bad
or friends body rot
friends
bradley bledsoe what's up dude uh got
another question guys which superhero
universe would you rather live in
marvel or dc party on dudes and love to
the discord fam
as much as i'm more excited for what dc
has coming out right now
i would want to live in the marvel verse
because
no no dc yeah i was like wait a minute
they just had that whole thing with half
the world being snapped away
i would i guess i would go in the dc
universe i would go
with the dc universe for the variety
alone just like the
if i was just like a random person
living in one of these universes i i
feel like
marvel's great but marvel's also based
on like just real places
yes whereas dc is yeah like places based
on real places but they're also a little
more fantastical so i would say yeah
that's true
that's what i would want to go uh derek
brown
i'll take that as a compliment what
pixar character uh you kind of look like
mr incredible
before he gained a bunch of weight
now i'm trying to remember if we
actually saw that thank you derek and
hillary beef what's up hillary
thank you i'm late just got home from
work happy birthday greg
thank you so much hillary you're right
on time for a b day wish thank you
hillary
she's great talk to her on patreon
julian morgan
whoa san diego theaters are open like an
hour away
it's more like two and a half to three
hours away
from us yeah i'm just telling you it's
really not
yeah uh but damn i didn't know san diego
theaters are open right now hey that
might be a decent option to actually go
like try to catch tenant or something
that'd be great
out of a day come back later tenant's
the only one i might consider driving
somewhere for yeah if you go to a place
where yeah there's like five people
yeah yeah that would be great to watch
be cool and if it's reserved seating i
could get a great seat i'm not going to
drive there for like a shitty scene
stand in line like such a great have you
ever like go there and stand in line
oh [ __ ] hate that yes no bueno
i just saw your comment in the chats
pocket thank you um
but maybe julian thanks for letting me
know i had no idea the san diego
theaters are open thank you
jacob neptune happy birthday greg and
hope you're doing well too
john uh with the batman coming out would
you guys want to preview an early joker
in that universe
no i don't wanna hear a preview out of i
want a preview of him in the second one
if anything
leave it be for now if there's like some
hint they have that there's a joker out
there
and and then you watch the second one
and then you're like
oh i didn't even realize that's what
they were alluded to that was a joke
then that would be cool but i don't want
anything like so obvious that it's just
because
then when they [ __ ] do do that when
that movie's done no matter how great it
is everyone's just gonna be talking
about joker the whole time you know yeah
and i feel like joker just got his own
movie so i feel like it would be very
very appropriate to leave him
mostly out of this batman i'd wait a
little bit
and then uh let's see here melanie
fabric
fella i've never known how to say your
last name melody
happy birthday greg so glad you're not
canceled yet john
professional curiosity what's your
favorite type of birthday cake
i love like a super chocolatey cake
like like just so so rich in chocolate
those are my favorite just like over
abundance of chocolate glitter
chocolate double chocolate i don't know
why it's my favorite but it is my
favorite
it's a classic [ __ ] like just like
overload chocolate and chocolate cake is
is is the cake or like my stomach hurts
after one slice
yeah you're like what is in this butter
yeah can i get a sprite please
yeah that's my favorite sir
thank you melody i appreciate that dear
yak attack
sorry guys i'm trying to get to a dinner
with my girlfriend yeah i
is all so sweet though happy birthday
uh thank you yak attack thanks for all
the awkward moments
who would you want to play you in a fut
in a feature film
i would want um i would want
finn wolfhard to play me because
he seems destined to be a douchebag down
the road i don't know if he's a
douchebag now
but i feel like finn wolfhard has the
capability of being a
total [ __ ] a few years from now i
feel like some reason
i just want him to play and then around
the time of that movie coming out
i want him to get cancelled so that way
they pull that movie out of theaters
the crying out was story i have a whole
plan and i'm going to be the one to
cancel
yeah dude melanie and
fabra that's how you say fabra okay
all right yeah that's who i wanna play
john who would you want play you
who would i wanna play me uh who plays
will on stranger things
i don't know no one knows who plays well
uh the kid who played
carl because he's got long hair now i
don't know who i want to play me now i
always wanted anton yelchin before but
but he is no longer with us
okay then we should have john cho play
you definitely i would be honored to
play that john
i want uh let's see let's get uh
aquafina to play me
ooh i want that i like that picture yeah
gender bend john
brendan v back at it thank you dude you
guys should check out
orville peck he got me back into country
music for pop i would recommend
let me screenshot this dude oh snap
thank you i'm screenshotting this
right now a lot of times people send
these these requests and then i often do
check them out eventually fund me
productions
happy birthday greg real question biggie
or tupac thank you brendan v for those
recommendations in super chat by the way
which one is wider i would go for tupac
uh personally
uh fund me thank you but and i would say
tupac he's the only one who's
between the two i've listened to biggie
before but tupac is the only one who i
will find myself actually searching for
like specific songs to like really
examine the lyrics
of [ __ ] he's talking about so i would
say tupac all right not bad
california knows how to party yeah it's
the only song i know by tupac he's done
anything else
no that's the reason he's regarded as
one of the greatest rappers
uh jose velazquez thank you jose
happy birthday greg gweg gweg love you
man
marriage choose some many more what
brings us together today
thank you jose that's really i really do
appreciate everyone's contributing here
we are going to wrap up in just a couple
minutes i've been uh
i'm trying to make sure where where
where is this thing johnny
seymour okay good speed round these
you gotta honor everyone um
derek cosby hey is this the first time
we're seeing you tara
maybe happy birthday you guys are great
how dare you say
you guys let me in on my birthday
[ __ ] it's not my pickle rick
thank you darry you look like a very
lovely woman 250 dead man
happy b day greg enjoy react videos
thanks you should check out our other
react videos
that was terrible you should take your
super chat back oh
duke pep thank you dude um as for your
suggestion i just watched that
i'm dante reaction to wap my first time
watching you um what the [ __ ] also
here's a five for your bday thanks duke
and dude watch more on dante i'm dante
is a
great great youtuber who's one of my
favorite youtubers he's a good dude
he's a really nice guy recently married
too yeah
you know he's nice if he got married
someone must have thought he was nice
enough to bury the bahamas
someone must think he's all right harry
wardman
hey happy birthday greg first live
stream for me well thanks for being here
harry
happy to have you here dude usually when
they're more thematic
it's easier to keep the things a little
bit more on a specific topic but thank
you harry
and eric horseman last super chat of the
day
eric horseman all the love to greg john
olivia and the best discord fan of any
channel ever
i really do love our discord i feel like
everyone's very personal
and it has real friendships there yeah
like
i don't i feel like they don't even talk
about movies and shows they just talk
about getting to know each other so
thank you eric for mentioning that
yeah seriously um and then i'll just do
a little checker
yeah yeah let's refresh her fresher
refreshes
you're going to want to drag that window
down though because we can see the
bottom of the screen
that's good no we're caught up here all
right oh never lose your nerd
last one of the day happy birthday you
bastard
and love you guys yeah bastard never
lose your nerd we
i love you i've always loved your name
never lose your nerd
all right guys we're gonna wrap up in
just a minute um
but yeah i gotta go uh spend some time
on lady right now you have to
and she's dying her hair i gotta help
her yeah you gotta fix this oh what
elia's here for the first time oh [ __ ]
we're about to leave
come back on the next one and hang with
us guys
i want some topic suggestions for the
next
live stream i'm gonna put out some
community posts that way for next week's
live stream like
what should be the theme of that one
what do you want to talk about um
i want to give a special thanks to
everyone who contributed in the super
chats
and uh the stream labs it's been i do
remember i'm dante from the reaction
rose days man
i i i really appreciate everyone who's
been here this entire time everyone has
contributed to
and a special thanks to everyone from
the patreon and discord as well i'm
gonna be putting up a video
of the reaction to that that you guys
made for us uh
well for me mainly i saw it but i really
shouldn't
it was inappropriate yeah um i think you
guys will really enjoy that
and um happy birthday to anyone else's
birthday it is today
happy early birthday and um happy
birthday to
um you know everyone else to charlie
sheen
charlie shade he's still kicking somehow
and
he's like ethan's tech world and anissa
la vigo and er
issa eric kkk
everyone who's contributed thank you so
much and um this is fun
it's a great way to spend a covered
birthday yeah it's an event it's a great
way to spend a covered birthday right
here with you guys thank you oh yeah
great birthday present the best birthday
pres it's a birthday present all year
round having you guys
support the channel john yes want to
close us out guys
thank you for watching thank you for
wishing greg a happy birthday and making
him feel so special
and uh i'll see you on the other side of
getting cancelled
peace